und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihn allen aus dem Weißen Haus zu
Washington heute ganz viel Pathos jede
Generation habe einen Moment in dem sie
für Demokratie und Freiheit einstehen
müsse und jetzt sei der Moment seiner
Generation gekommen sagt der älteste
Präsident der US-Geschichte und Kündig
damit an dass er es noch mal wissen will
Joe Biden geht in den Wahlkampf und es
könnte sein dass wir nächstes Jahr eine
Wiederauflage des Duells vom letzten Mal
erleben beiden gegen Trump aus
Washington Benjamin Daniel
[Applaus]
als Joe Biden für eine wirtschaftsrede
heute vor die bauarbeitergewerkschaft in
Washington tritt wird er mit Jubel und
sprech gehören empfangen der
US-Präsident will es also noch mal
wissen
ich habe Amerikas Zukunft nie so
optimistisch gesehen wir bewegen etwas
schaffen Jobs das produzierende Gewerbe
erlebt eine Wiedergeburt Leute können
sich Krankenversicherung wieder leisten
Gemeinden die sich abgehängt fühlten
können langsam wieder durchatmen wegen
ihnen und dem was wir gemeinsam umsetzen
jetzt müssen wir weitermachen und den
Job zu Ende bringen wir müssen uns daran
erinnern wer wir sind wir sind die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika und es
gibt nichts dass wir nicht schaffen
können
kein großer Auftritt keine Inszenierung
lediglich dieses Video postet das Weiße
Haus um Punkt 6 Uhr ortszeitwashington
Joe Biden wirft für die
Präsidentschaftswahl 2024 seinen Hut
erneut in den Ring er teilt hart aus
gegen jene die Demokratie und Freiheiten
oder das Recht auf Abtreibung
einschränken wollen
als ich vor vier Jahren angetreten bin
habe ich gesagt wir kämpfen um die Seele
Amerikas und das tun wir noch immer wir
müssen uns der Frage stellen ob wir in
den kommenden Jahren mehr Freiheit und
Rechte oder weniger haben wollen
mit 80 Jahren ist er bereits jetzt der
älteste US-Präsident aller Zeiten viele
sehen das als Problem auch unter den
Demokraten dennoch muss der Amtsinhaber
wohl nicht mit ernsthafter Konkurrenz
aus den eigenen Reihen rechnen auch
seine Stellvertreterin Kamera Harris die
viele zu Beginn ihrer Amtszeit als
mögliche Kandidatin gesehen hatten soll
auf ihrem jetzigen Posten bleiben und so
kann sich Joe Biden auf die
republikanische Konkurrenz konzentrieren
Donald Trump postete heute als Reaktion
sein eigenes Video in dem er Joe Biden
als den schlechtesten Präsidenten aller
Zeiten beschreibt wir werden Joe Biden
2024 besiegen wir werden unsere
Wirtschaft retten die Inflation
zerschlagen die Invasion an unserer
Südgrenze stoppen wir werden die würde
unserer Nation wiederherstellen und wir
werden den Dritten Weltkrieg verhindern
damit dass auch Floridas
republikanischer Gouverneur Ron desentis
früher oder später ins Rennen einsteigen
wird und so ist später spätestens ab
heute klar der Wahlkampf in Amerika für
2024 hat begonnen
[Musik]
Phil Murphy ist bei uns der Gouverneur
des Bundesstaats New Jersey Parteifreund
von Joe Biden governighting
guten Abend
es gibt Gerüchte dass sie selbst
Präsident werden wollen wie überrascht
sind sie denn von beiden jetzt heute
oder was für Sie immer klar dass beiden
eine zweite Amtszeit will
ich bin da überhaupt nicht überrascht
wir wussten dass das kommt wir haben
schon lange darüber gesprochen mit der
Präsidenten und er verdient eine
Wiederwahl er hat selber privat und auch
öffentlich angekündigt dass er bald eine
Ankündigung machen würde es ist ein
toller Tag für ihn und Vizepräsidentin
ein großer Tag für die Demokraten und
Amerika das ist genau so wie es sein
sollte jetzt sagt Joe beiden heute er
klingt zumindest so als könne nur er die
Demokratie retten ist es wirklich so
schlimm bestellt um Amerika
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es so
schlimm ist aber er hat natürlich recht
er war eine stabilisierende Kraft für
unser Land das geht über die Politik
hinaus schauen Sie sich mal an was er
geleistet hat in der Innenpolitik und
seine starke Führerschaft des Bündnisses
gegen Russlands brutalen Angriffskrieg
er hat letztlich Donald Trump schon
einmal geschlagen und sollte Donald
Trump der Kandidat sein dass er bewiesen
dass er ihn schlagen kann und aus all
den Gründen ist er der Kandidat und ist
gut jetzt scheint das aber die Menschen
in den USA etwas anders zu sehen es gibt
eine aktuelle Umfrage nach der 70% der
Befragten eben nicht wollen dass beiden
noch mal antritt und sogar eine Mehrheit
bei den demokratischen Wählerinnen und
Wählern sagt er soll lieber nicht noch
mal antreten Rückenwind sieht anders aus
oder
sicherlich Christian ich schaue mir die
Umfragen an und ich denke nicht dass wir
dort enden werden seine Leistung sind
klar konzentrieren Sie sich auf drei
große Gesetze die der Kongress
verabschiedet hat und er unterschrieben
hat das
inflationsbekämpfungsgesetz das Chips
technologiegesetz das über parteiliche
Infrastruktur gesetzt das heißt Hunderte
von Milliarden Dollar werden ausgegeben
die einen positiven wirtschaftlichen
Effekt haben werden während der Nächte
nächsten 18 Monate zwischen heute und
der Wahl und ich denke wenn wir da mal
diese Dynamik erkennen die sich darauf
baute während sich auf die Umfragen
verändern
dann reden wir jetzt noch über das Alter
von von Joe Biden das ist nämlich vielen
WLAN tatsächlich ein wichtiger Punkt bei
der ganzen Sache Donald Trump schlachtet
das ja bereits jetzt die gesamte Zeit
aus obwohl er selber ja nicht viel
jünger ist aber doch irgendwie jünger
wirkt beiden wirkt immer wieder als sei
er nicht mehr fit für den Stress einer
neuen Kampagne
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das zu
unterschreibe wir kennen ihn gut wir
treffen die privat vor ein paar Monaten
erstmal bei uns zu Hause ich sehen
wahrscheinlich zweimal diese Woche noch
ich denke er ist sehr fit für das Amt
und sie haben richtig gesagt wenn Donald
Trump der Kandidat wird dann ist er nur
ein paar Jahre jünger als Präsident
behalten und ich denke wir haben das
gesehen ich habe die Innenpolitik
angesprochen schauen Sie sich seine
Führerschaft an und zusammen mit
Deutschland und Deutschland verdient
Anerkennung dafür schauen Sie sich seine
Führerschaft an im Widerstand gegen
Putins Angriffskrieg ich denke er ist
Aufgabe gewachsen
das heißt wir können uns auf eine
trotzdem auf eine ganz neue Episode von
sleepy Joe Talk einstellen
also wissen Sie ich glaube die andere
Seite ist da wirklich schamlos wie die
über den Präsidenten sprechen und ihn
darstellen
also ehrlich gesagt das gilt ja auch für
viele gewählte Beamte tatsächlich ist es
so dass er ein sehr starker gesunder
Mensch ist der wirklich großartige
Führerschaft zeigt sowohl in der
Innenpolitik als auch in der
Außenpolitik und ich glaube das wird
auch weiterhin zeigen braucht Amerika
wirklich noch einmal ein Duell beiden vs
Trump
also ich weiß nicht ob wir das brauchen
aber wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit darauf
hinweist so und die umfragen sagen dass
das wahrscheinlich ist dann hat Joe
beiden bewiesen dass er dann fand
schlagen kann er stand für Stabilität
für amerikanische Werte oder war genau
was wir brauchten in unserem Land und
das gilt auch weiterhin und der Kontrast
ist deutlich und zukunftspräsidenten
sagt der demokratische gewonneneur des
Bundesstaates New Jersey Phil Murphy aus
New York New Jersey bei uns in der
Sendung
das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am frühen Abend aufgezeichnet so
jetzt zu einem ersten
Nachrichtenüberblick und damit zu dir
Hanna ja die Bundeswehr will am Abend
ihre evakuierungsflüge aus dem Sudan
beenden Deutsche die sich noch in dem
afrikanischen konfliktland befinden
sollen laut dem Auswärtigen Amt und dem
Verteidigungsministerium in den nächsten
Tagen von Partnerländern ausgeflogen
werden insgesamt hat Deutschland seit
Sonntag mehr als 500 Menschen außer
Landes gebracht über das Mandat für die
Rettungsmission soll morgen nachträglich
der Bundestag abstimmen zudem will sich
die Bundesregierung die Möglichkeit
offenheiten sie bis Ende Mai vorzuführen
nach der Messerattacke in einem
Fitnessstudio in Duisburg vor einer
Woche haben die Ermittler Hinweise auf
einen terroristisches Motiv dies habe
eine Auswertung des Mobiltelefons des
Tatverdächtigen Syrers ergeben erklärte
die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft Düsseldorf
die nun die weiteren Ermittlungen
übernehmen wird bei der Attacke am
vergangenen Dienstag waren vier Menschen
schwer verletzt worden eine Person
schwebt noch immer in Lebensgefahr der
mutmaßliche Täter sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft
und auch in einem anderen Fall der heute
bekannt wurde geht es um ein
islamistisches Motiv in Hamburg wurde
eine Syrer festgenommen ihm wird von der
dortigen Generalstaatsanwaltschaft
vorgeworfen gemeinsam mit seinem Bruder
einen Sprengstoffanschlag auf zivile
Ziele geplant zu haben den Ermittlern
zufolge handelten sie dabei aus einer
radikal islamistischen Grundhaltung
heraus der 28-Jährige Haupt Beschuldigte
soll online Grundstoffe gekauft haben um
einen Sprengstoffgürtel zu bauen auch
sein jüngerer Bruder wurde festgenommen
die Corona Impfempfehlung für gesunde
Kinder und Jugendliche soll laut Plänen
der Ständigen Impfkommission künftig
komplett entfallen das geht aus einem
Beschlussentwurf hervor grund dafür sei
das geringe Risiko für Minderjährige
schwer an Kurve 19 zu erkranken auch für
andere Gruppen sind Neuerungen geplant
für Menschen ab 60 Bewohner von
Pflegeeinrichtungen und Personen mit
bestimmten Vorerkrankungen wird eine
jährliche Auffrischimpfung empfohlen
gleiches gilt für medizinisches Personal
an das sieht es bei allen gesunden unter
60 aus Sie müssen laut STIKO nicht
weiter Geburtstag werden
knapp drei Wochen vor den parlaments-
und Präsidentschaftswahlen in der Türkei
sind bei landesweiten Razzien mehr als
100 Personen festgenommen worden ihnen
wird vorgeworfen die verbotene
Arbeiterpartei Kurdistans zu
unterstützen oder den Festgenommenen
sollen unter anderem Journalisten
Anwälte und hochrangige Politiker der
prokurdischen Oppositionspartei HDP sein
die Wahl am 14 Mai könnte knapp ausgehen
Umfragen hat der Kandidat der
sozialdemokratischen
chp-chancen den türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan in seinem Amt abzulösen
gut gemeint heißt nicht automatisch gut
gemacht neustes Beispiel dafür die
Getreideexporte der Ukraine die EU
wollte alles tun damit sie weitergehen
können und auch Länder erreichen in
Afrika etwa die davon existenziell
abhängig sind das hat jetzt allerdings
zu erheblichen Nebenwirkungen geführt
die Handelserleichterungen für die
Ukraine bescheren Europa eine
ukrainische getreideschwämme das drückt
die Preise die Bauern in den
osteuropäischen Ländern bleiben auf
ihren eigenen Erzeugnissen sitzen Polen
Ungarn die Slowakei waren die ersten die
einen Importstopp verhängten dort
erreicht die Solidarität mit der Ukraine
ihre Grenzen weil sie den eigenen
Bürgern Probleme macht
Krisensitzung jetzt bei der EU sie
stellt Hilfen in Aussicht unter Hilfe
hat berichtet aus seinem Hafen in
Rumänien für den sich ebenfalls viel
geändert hat
es herrscht Dauerbetrieb am neuen
getreideterminal von Konstanza der Krieg
im Nachbarland Ukraine hat den
rumänischen Hafen wach gerüttelt die
Schiffe stehen nun hier Schlange sie
schlagen rund 25 Prozent des
ukrainischen Getreides um sagte die
Orell palait von hier geht es nach
Westeuropa und den afrikanische Länder
die Situation hat sich seit Kriegsbeginn
verbessert wir haben den Fluss des
ukrainischen Getreides besser
organisiert
die Ukraine hat ein Transportproblem
Agrarexporte aus Odessa sind schwierig
und nur möglich dank eines unabkommens
Russland droht nun es auslaufen zu
lassen
doch Konstanzer ist bereits ausgelastet
und andere Transportwege teuer nach
einem Jahr Krieg ist außerdem die starke
ukrainische Konkurrenz weniger gern
gesehen
die Ukraine drücken die Preise die
Getreide ist viel billiger
die Getreidepreise liegen nun unter
Vorkriegsniveau auch weil die Ukrainer
lieber im nahen Nachbarmarkt verkaufen
als teuer weiter über Land zu
transportieren
die Bauern in Polen demonstrieren gegen
das ukrainische Preisdumping die
polnische und andere osteuropäische
Regierungen verhängten sogar einen
Importstopp in Bruch mit EU-Regeln
unsere Landwirte erleiden welche
Turbulenzen es gibt auf den Märkten für
Agrarprodukte langsam versteht das auch
die EU-Kommission die EU streitet Polen
verplomben ukrainische Lastwagen lässt
nur Transit zu auf andere Märkte die
EU-Kommission bietet Hilfszahlungen
verlangt aber offene Grenzen für
ukrainische einführen vielleicht auch
weil sie weiß dass ein viel größeres
Problem droht wenn der Hafen von Odessa
nämlich gar nichts mehr exportieren kann
wenn Russland das unabkommen in drei
Wochen auslaufen lässt
im Moment sieht es nicht so aus als wird
das Abkommen verlängert dann bedeutet
das dass sich die Versorgungslage auf
dem globalen Agrarmarkt über Nacht
wieder deutlich verschärft und das
bedeutet im Endeffekt steigende Preise
und mehr Hunger in Entwicklungsländer
der Mangel in Afrika hieße außerdem eine
Schwämme hier die Ukraine wird dann noch
mehr Getreide über den Landweg in die EU
schicken der Seeweg muss also offen
bleiben um den Weltmarkt in der Balance
zu halten
alles hängt mit allem zusammen es ist
kompliziert und die Menschen in der
Ukraine haben noch ganz andere Sorgen
immer noch und immer mehr unser Reporter
Dara Hass unser D ist viele Wochen quer
durchs Land unterwegs er hat uns heute
eine Geschichte von dort versprochen
über die er sagt sie liebe sie liege ihm
am aller aller allermeisten am Herzen
wenn ein Reporter so etwas sagt sollten
wir genau hinschauen
diana ist 16 Jahre alt geboren in eine
Soldatenfamilie den Krieg erlebte sie
bereits 2016 hier im Don Bass wo ihr
Vater kämpfte heute ist ihre Mutter
Offizierin in der ukrainischen Armee
ihre Eltern haben eine Hilfsorganisation
gegründet dieser Hilfe hat sich das
Mädchen verschrieben
ich sehe meine Zukunft für die nächsten
Jahre so es wird jede Menge wieder
aufbauen nach unserem Sieg geben und
deshalb möchte ich Krisenmanagement
studieren damit ich genau das Wissen
dafür haben werde
Diana musste früher erwachsen werden
vier Tage wird sie bei ihrer Mutter im
Kriegsgebiet bleiben die Familie lebt
den Lemberg
meine größte Angst ist wenn es ein
Luftangriff auf Lemberg gibt und ich
nicht weiß wo diana ist das ist Horror
wohl nur eine Mutter im Rang einer
Offizierin hat hier ein Gefühl von
Kontrolle den Rettungswagen umgebaut zu
einer mobilen Hausarztpraxis hat Dianas
Familie mit Hilfe spanischer Spender
organisiert selbst kardiologische
Kontrollen sind möglich
ich bin absolut gesund ich werde 100
Jahre alt hat mir der Doktor gesagt
viele Anwohner in diesem Vorort von
Kramer Torsten sind alt der Gang ins
nächste Hospital beschwerlich und der
Krieg lastet auf ihren Seelen
du hörst den Lärm der Luft Angriffe
einer nach dem anderen hinterlässt einen
Fingerabdruck auf deinem Nervensystem
aber wir müssen damit leben ich werde
nicht weggehen ich werde warten und wir
haben gelernt zu warten
erwachsene Frauen kämpfen mit Tränen
eine 16-Jährige will sie stützen auch
das macht der Krieg mit Menschen es ist
wirklich hart es ist nicht leicht für
mich mit den Schicksalen in Berührung zu
kommen es fällt mir leichter am Telefon
darüber zu sprechen statt von Angesicht
zu Angesicht
es geht weiter zum nächsten Treffpunkt
dort übergeben sie Hilfsgüter für die
umkämpfte statt anifa dort fahren Sie
nicht selbst hin die Fahrt dorthin hält
auch Dianas Mutter für viel zu
gefährlich
zurück nach Deutschland und zu Diana ja
Wärmepumpen gelten ja als
Schlüsseltechnologie bei der wärmewende
doch nun will einer der größten
Hersteller des Landes nämlich fismann
offenbar eben diese Sparte an einen
US-Konzern verkaufen das wirft einige
Fragen auf Valerie Haller denn
wirtschaftlich läuft es ja eigentlich
mehr als gut für das Unternehmen was
steckt also hinter diesen Plänen er
darüber können wir momentan eigentlich
nur spekulieren weil es dazu noch nichts
offizielle es gibt aber ein wichtiger
Punkt ist vermutlich die übermächtige
Konkurrenz aus Asien angelockt durch
Robert Habicht wärmepumpenplan
Hersteller aus China Korea Japan drängen
auf den europäischen Markt mit bald
riesigen Mengen und da kann eben nur
mithalten wer wirklich groß ist
Viessmann will anscheinend lieber jetzt
aus einer Position der Stärke heraus
verkaufen als später aus der Not heraus
und der große Wettbewerb schon da ist
rund 11 milliar Millionen Euro legt er
amerikanische
klimaanlagenhersteller Carrier global
für viessmanns Wärmepumpen angeblich auf
den Tisch und das ist ein Vielfaches des
aktuellen Marktwerts was bedeutet das
denn für den Standort Deutschland wenn
so eine Zukunftstechnologie in US Hand
übergeht nun Viessmann ist vermutlich
erst der Anfang andere deutsche
Heizungsbauer kommen auch unter Druck
durch die asiatische Billigkonkurrenz
und könnten ebenso zu
Übernahmekandidaten werden und
Deutschland läuft schon gefahren
Know-how und Innovationen ausländische
Firmen zu verlieren für den Verbraucher
übrigens muss das nicht unbedingt ein
Nachteil sein in Zukunft werden
vermutlich deutlich mehr Geräte
verschiedenster Anbieter verfügbar sein
was sie günstiger machen dürfte dem
deutschen Mittelstand freiliches damit
natürlich nicht geholfen vielen Dank
Valerie für diese Einschätzung
auch die dritte Verhandlungsrunde
zwischen deutscher Bahn und EVG der
Eisenbahn und
verkehrsverkehrsgewerkschaft ist bisher
ohne Ergebnis geblieben die Bahn hat ein
neues Angebot vorgelegt eine
inflationsausgleichsprämie von fast 3000
€ und zwischen acht und zehn Prozent
mehr Geld das reicht der EVG allerdings
nicht sie fordert mehr und vor allem für
die unteren Lohngruppen sollte auch
morgen keine Einigung gelingen drohen
weitere Bahnstreiks
in Deutschland sind Einkommensteuer und
Sozialabgaben im internationalen
Vergleich weiterhin auf einem sehr hohen
Niveau das bestätigt eine neue
Auswertung der Organisation für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung OECD demnach liegen die
Abgaben bei einem verheirateten Paar mit
Kindern hierzulande bei 40,8 Prozent nur
in Belgien ist die Belastung mit 45,5%
höher der Durchschnitt in den
OECD-Staaten beträgt 29,4%
. harry Belafonte ist tot ein vielfach
ausgezeichneter Sänger und Schauspieler
und ein ebenso einflussreicher Kämpfer
für Menschenrechte in den USA und auf
der ganzen Welt er starb im Alter von 96
Jahren in seiner Heimatstadt New York
[Musik]
diese Silben machten ihn zum Weltstar
mit der samtigen Stimme belafontes floss
karibische Leichtigkeit in den
amerikanischen Musik Mainstream der 50er
Jahre
seine Stimme brachte er aber immer auch
ein als Aktivist für Menschenrechte
[Musik]
viele haben mich gefragt wann ich als
Künstler entschieden habe einen Aktivist
zu werden aber es war genau andersrum
ich war schon politisch aktiv als ich
Künstler wurde das macht schon einen
Unterschied in welchem Rhythmus du dein
Leben lebst
bellafontes Leben zurück muss bewegt er
ist befreundet mit Martin Luther King
nimmt an Protestmärschen für die Rechte
der Schwarzen in den USA teilen
[Applaus]
1985 initiiert er das we are the world
Projekt für Afrika zusammen mit Michael
Jackson und anderen Superstars und er
engagiert sich für UNICEF
bellafonte ein Brückenbauer zwischen
Hollywood Washington und der
Bürgerrechtsbewegung
ich habe mir die Bedingungen angeschaut
unter denen ich aufgewachsen bin und
habe entschieden dass ich meinen
Einfluss nutzen möchte um sie zu ändern
für die die nach mir kommen
harry Belafonte sei einer der wenigen
Menschen die im Alter radikaler geworden
sein sagt ein enger Freund mal über ihn
diese Stimme ist jetzt verstummt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
von einem echten Weltstar jetzt wieder
zurück hier nach Deutschland 12 Tage
liegen zwischen der vollmundigen
Ankündigung eines Chefredakteurs jetzt
müsse Geschichte umgeschrieben werden
und der kleinen lauten Entschuldigung
bei den Lesern 12 Tage einer der größten
presse-skandale in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik und ein Desaster für die
Zeitschrift Stern damals mit 1,8
Millionen Auflage bei den allergrößten
dieses Landes heute ist es genau 40
Jahre her dass der Stern aus Hamburg der
Welt seine Hitler Tagebücher bis
präsentierte bzw das was eine
abenteuerliche Koalition aus Leichtsinn
Geldgier und Ruhmes sucht als Hitlers
Tagebücher ausgab alles gelogen
das sind sie die echten falschen
Hitler-Tagebücher 40 Jahre lang ruhten
Sie im Safe des stern jetzt werden sie
dem Bundesarchiv in Koblenz zugänglich
gemacht die 62 glatten Erzielen von
einer Weltsensation die zu einer
beispiellosen Blamage in der junggrund
Pressegeschichte geführt hat was war
natürlich der größte anzunehmende Gau
für den Stern und bis heute sicher einer
der größten Medienskandale überhaupt und
im Nachhinein wirkt es wirklich
unglaublich vor allem wenn man den
Inhalt der Klatten kennt der ja wirklich
oft an Banalität und auch an wirklich
verwirrenden Aussagen kaum zu verbieten
ist Hamburg 25 April 83 über 200
Journalisten wollen beim Welt Ereignis
dabei sein Hitler exklusiv die
Geschichte des Nationalsozialismus muss
neu geschrieben werden heißt es im
Mittelpunkt stern-reporter Gerd
Heidemann insgesamt 9,4 Millionen D-Mark
zahlte der Stern für 62 Tagebücher mit
original Hitler Unterschrift
man war im Grunde besoffen von der
Vorstellung jetzt zum ersten Mal
wirklich den authentischen Hitler zu
hören und die Vorstellung war natürlich
so hieß es ja auch in der
Pressekonferenz dass man mit diesen
Büchern einen ganz neuen Blick auf die
NS-Vergangenheit bekommt und die
Vorstellung der Verantwortlichen war
auch dass man mit dieser neuen Sicht auf
die Geschichte selber in die Geschichte
eingeht das ist der Mann der Hitler neu
erfunden hat Konrad Kujau ein Big
gnadeter Fälscher und Hitler Verehrer
die Geschichte des schwäbischen Tüftlers
war genial eine sogenannte
führermaschine verließ am 21 April 45
mit persönlichen Unterlagen Hitlers das
umkämpfte Berlin sie stürzte im
sächsischen Donnersdorf ab der Absturz
war real alles andere frei erfunden
hitler hatte nie Tagebuch geführt seine
persönlichen Aufzeichnungen wurden Ende
April auf dem Obersalzberg verbrannt
wenn man die Tagebücher komplett liest
und anguckt man sieht eigentlich ein
systematische Versuch Adolf Hitler zu
verharmlosen er war gegen die Nürnberger
rassengesetzter Eva gegen die
Bücherverbrennung er war nicht
informiert über den Holocaust der kujo
hitler war nahbar menschlich und gütig
Hinweise auf Verbrechen und
Judenverfolgung fehlten einen Tag nach
der von Hitler angeordneten
Reichspogromnacht mit 1.300 Toten heißt
es bei Coolio das geht nicht dass
unserer Wirtschaft durch einige
Hitzköpfe Millionen und aber Millionen
Werte vernichtet werden allein schon ein
Glas
im Mai 43 werden in Auschwitz täglich
tausende Jüdinnen und Juden ermordet da
notiert Hitler
mein Magen leiden hat sich
verschlechtert ich esse nur noch
Haferschleim nur ein Mensch hält mich
noch aufrecht Eva
was bleibt ein gefälschte Hitler der
nichts vom Genozid wusste und ein
journalistischer Kauf von dem sich der
Stern bis heute nicht richtig erholt hat
neben diesem Film von Chris hat Läpple
gerade eben ist natürlich immer auch der
legendäre strong zu empfehlen von Helmut
Dietl dessen aber witzige Dialoge
offenbar nur noch von der Realität
übertroffen wurden
so wir sagen damit tschüss und bedanken
uns dass sie dabei waren und gegen 0:15
Uhr begrüßt sie dann hier Gundula Gause
mit unserem heute journal-update ein
angenehmen Abend noch tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend im Augenblick stehen die
Zeichen auf spätfroste wenn es wärmer
werden sollte dann müsste diese Wärme
irgendwie aus Südwesteuropa zu uns
kommen das sehen Sie in diesem roten
Pfeil dass sich die Wärme so ein
bisschen in unsere Richtung auf den Weg
macht heute Nacht allerdings wird es
richtig frostig es droht Luftfrost
Temperaturen von -4 bis -1 Grad ganz
verbreitet in Deutschland gibt es aber
Bodenfrost empfindliche Pflanzen sollten
Sie also besser schützen denn häufig ist
die Nacht klar oder eine locker bewölkt
das bildet sich auch mal Nebel hier in
der Nordsee fällt etwas Regen und auch
in Süddeutschland kann es regnen am
alten Rand kann auch mal eine
Schneeflocke dabei sein morgen ziehen
Schauer von der Nordseeküste die Elbe
entlang weiter in Richtung Uckermark bei
einem West Nordwestwind freundliche
sieht auf Rügen aus und auch ein
Ostfriesland und über den Mittelgebirgen
werden sich Sonne und wolkenfreundlich
miteinander abwechseln genauso wie in
Süddeutschland einzig direkt am
Alpenrand zwischen dem Berchtesgaden und
im Allgäu sind die Wolken dichter und
bringen zum Teil noch kräftigeren Regen
mit die Temperaturen liegen morgen bei 8
Grad im Vogtland oder auch im Westerwald
und maximal 15 Grad am Oberrhein am
Donnerstag Wetter die Temperaturen am
Oberrhein schon bis 19 Grad am Freitag
kommt dann vom Besten neuer Regen mit
Gewittern heran und am Samstag wird es
vor allen Dingen Nordosten sehr
freundlich sein und wie sie hier am
Trend für Berlin sehen können wird das
lange erste Maiwochenende dort recht
freundlich bei Temperaturen über 15 Grad
und es gibt keinen Bodenfrost mehr